hello and welcome to the to this uh
public lecture organized by the science
institute for theory of computing
uh my name is peter barton i'm the
associate director um
the simon's institute's the leading
venue for uh collaborative research and
theoretical computer science
uh it brings together researchers
top researchers and the next generation
of outstanding
young scholars to explore deep unsolved
problems
about the nature and limits of
computation the institute's core
activities
revolve around semester-long research
programs on specific topics in the
foundations of computing and related
fields
uh and this semester although we're
operating online only
so far we have two very active programs
one on probability geometry and
computation in high dimensions and one
on the theory of reinforcement learning
the institute's recently set up a new
law
and society fellowship that's designed
to enhance institute programs that
address technologies um with impacts on
human society uh with implications for
for ethics law and policy
and this fellowship's aimed at
researchers who focused on
uh the broader societal implications of
the techniques and the technologies that
are addressed
are addressed in our programs uh and
we're delighted to welcome our first
law and society fellow tom gilbert tom's
a phd candidate in the
in machine ethics and epistemology at uc
berkeley
uh his background's in philosophy
sociology and political theory he has
an m fill in uh political thought and
intellectual history from cambridge
university
and his work focuses on the ethical and
political consequences of
using machine learning in organizational
decision making
and implications for the design of ai
systems that are fair
safe and accountable he's participating
in this semester's program on the theory
of reinforcement learning
and his talk today is titled hard
choices in
artificial intelligence welcome tom
thanks peter uh it's a pleasure to be
giving this talk
which is i should say based off of
collaborative work with
members of my my main affiliation on
campus uh
prior to simon's just was the center for
human-compatible
ai stewart russell's lab um as well as
uh
a graduate student in the ieor
department um
so i'll just go ahead and jump in here
uh and i i wanted to start off by
kind of framing what i'm gonna say in
the talk in relation to a lot of the
themes that emerged from the boot camp
um last week which i would describe as
not simply technical problems but also
philosophical in nature which is uh you
know this more ambitious conceptual
landscape of asking
you know should we conceive of hri as
studying under actually dynamical
systems and that's what human
relationships
are in fact are under actuary dynamical
systems
that in principle could be modeled
formally um we have interesting
questions with covariate shift where
the notion of modeling and learning
rewards
at training time might be fundamentally
different
or not correlated at deployment time uh
we have interesting we saw interesting
questions in these
in the talks that were given about
counter factual reasoning about how to
compare
uh rl policies and ro optimization
versus
the business as usual equivalent in a
human case
uh for medical interventions for example
like what should a doctor do versus what
would the ro policy recommend for a
certain line of treatment
and then finally this like kind of deep
ontological question of like how do we
import
uh environmental principles whether
those are from physics whether from
transportation whether they're from
medicine
uh and interpret them such that we can
specify
the system uh through constraints uh
and does that require domain expertise
does it require
certain kinds of formal assumptions what
is the boundary line there
and i i was reminded through many of
these talks of
of what i wanted to say uh which which
broadly just just to kind of make this
concrete i mean
we encounter questions with an automated
vehicle
and we ask you know how many parameters
uh does it take
uh to make a simulation robust to
reality which is to say how do we make
sure the a b is safe
if we just traded in simulation rather
than if we use a real world vehicle
and make it drive actual miles in the
real world how do we compare simulation
versus the world in that sense through
parameterization
and the the kind of tldr for this talk
is that i think there are reasonable
answers to that question
but that they are not strictly formal
and
that kind of abstract line uh
between answers to that that are
reasonable
which is to say recognizable to the
people who will be affected by these
systems the actual stakeholders
the domain experts who are most familiar
with regulatory policy
um is is a landscape that i'm going to
characterize in terms of vagueness
uh so this is a technical kind of
philosophical concept it's an ancient
concept
um that as i've continued through my phd
work i've found to be
increasingly not not just relevant but
really constitutive
of this emerging discipline of machine
ethics
uh ai governance ai safety and and for a
lot of how i think about issues in rl
so for the rest of the talk i'll
basically be
exposing this concept through as many
concrete examples as i can think of
and i should say for the purpose of this
talk i'm going to define
vagueness as the practical absence of
conceptual boundaries
when you are attempting to develop an ai
system for a given domain
uh which is to say it's kind of a
generalized
version of the problem of
misspecification which is something that
people in ai safety worry extensively
about it's increasingly no problem in rl
especially multi-agent rl whether that's
with humans or just other
ai agents um and so in a sense what i'm
saying in this talk is misspecification
has a very long very rich
uh intellectual history behind it and it
really falls under this notion of vegas
so again just just to kind of set up
the the gestalt shift that i'm trying to
make here
um a lot of public discussions of
automated vehicles and and just machine
ethics more broadly
uh and i should say a lot of i think
technical work as well
in this in this domain of value
alignment i think still
is inclined to think of the
ethical dilemmas of developing ai in
terms of trolley
problems which you know i think we're
all familiar with at this point
uh the classic question of should i
divert the trolley or the vehicle in
this case
to uh intentionally harm
one person or fewer people uh for the
sake of saving
a larger number or should i not do that
and often
the kind of legacy of this is tied to uh
you know some version of pitting content
ethics against utilitarianism
and i think what's significant here is
that this thought experiment
which has its own long history assumes
deterministic dynamics
it assumes a discrete action space it
assumes complete control
over in this case the agent as well as
the environment
in terms of completely and exhaustively
well-defined objects
and i think this is quite limited
and i think it doesn't do a good job of
capturing the reality
of the choices that are faced by
developers when they're dealing with
actual systems
um and i think it's i think it's frankly
kind of missing the point
and to illuminate a kind of even longer
history here
uh this notion of the sororities paradox
i think
is is much more second for first just as
a starting point here
so the idea behind this alternative
thought experiment
is if i show you a pile of grains of
sand
and i ask you you know how many more
grains of sand
would i have to add to this uh pile
uh before it would become a heap so if
you think of this notion of heapness
the the thought experiment is how many
grains of sand does it take to
constitute
a heap uh this goes back to ancient
greece so this is thousands of years old
uh and there are many different
canonical answers to this question
uh in terms of whether you think there
is an objective answer
uh but we maybe don't know it uh or
there are various degrees of confidence
in what we think it is
you could argue that different kinds of
people could legitimately answer the
question differently because we use the
term heap differently
or you could argue that there's no
answer you could argue that it's
it might be semantically meaningless to
try to provide some ultimate
ultimate determinant answer to that
question and i think
those are the canonical schools of
thought i think they're all relevant
for how we should think about ai
development and also like reinforcement
learning in particular
um because of what i'm going to describe
in this talk as
the set of commitments that you are
making
to the world as you believe it to exist
when you are developing a system
so to elaborate on that a little bit
when you are designing
a system uh for example the model based
model free distinction
in terms of how you believe a system
should be enabled to learn about the
world what kind of representation it
should be able to have of it
uh how you go about practically training
it and what forms of validation you
think are appropriate and then how you
go about integrating that system
into the actual environment at
deployment
uh those map onto these
canonical schools of thought with
respect to how you answer the psoriasis
paradox
uh and that's that's kind of the deep
point that i want to make in this talk i
will circle back to this with more
concrete instances i'm just giving a
taste right now
um so the the structure of the talk i'll
give different examples of this
uh one with respect to
this problem of causality of of defining
counterfactual interventions that you
can make with an ai system
uh another is this landscape of what
i'll call normative indeterminacy
and finally this notion of situated
publics uh
as as part of i think what what will
constitute the criterion for how these
sorts of choices should be made
and for each of these i'm going to draw
a contrast with
um a school of thought or representative
that i think is
at the moment widely cited or widely
trusted in
either the a landscape ai ethics
landscape or rl landscape
and and set up a contrast between that
approach
and and what i'll instead be proposing
at
a philosophical level so i'll start with
causality
uh and in particular the the the
influence of
judea pearl's uh formalization of
graphical models
as a way to to think about causality uh
in in the context of ai systems so uh
these five necessary steps of causal
analysis are something that
uh pearl and his students have often
forwarded
as a superior refined
model of how to evaluate uh
interventions or rather to think of
causality in terms of interventions
which is basically to
be able to assume deterministic dynamics
under conditions of uncertainty so the
idea here is
if you follow this procedure uh through
through a specific set of tools such as
do calculus
uh you can basically evaluate uh
whether a certain kind of causal chain
makes sense or not with respect to the
problem that you care about
uh the sequence of defining
in terms of expressing the target
quantity assume identify estimate and
test is the sequence that pearl
basically proposes
um and i think what i want to really
emphasize here is the steps of
identification and estimation
so you have this target quantity
whatever it is you care about whatever
it is you're trying to account for
whether it's
why is the grass wet uh you know
how what uh what would it entail if i
treated sepsis one way rather than some
other way
uh you you you try to determine the
causal chain of sequence there in terms
of like what you think caused the
illness
how you think the illness is going to
change over time and what a certain kind
of an action would do to intervene on
that sequence
and then there's this work of estimation
which is to say
you you did you you decide the
conditions of uncertainty in terms of
how confident you are
and how much information you would need
in order to evaluate that
sequence as you've mapped it out in this
in this graphical model
and i want to draw a contrast here with
the work of david lewis
who is another philosopher
preceding pearl who has instead
emphasized
the way in which uh causality and more
specifically counter factual reasoning
which is just to say you know why does
the world work one way rather than some
other way
or what would be the likely result if i
acted in a way other than
the way i'm acting now uh and and lewis
was very clear and consistent in his
works
that the notion of a counterfactual was
inherently vague
he says this in the second paragraph of
his most famous book
uh i i presented an alongside quotation
here
uh from an earlier paper in which he
he's sort of challenging this notion of
the way in which what he calls an
adequate understanding
uh would have doesn't have to make a
certain kind of reference to
unactualized possibilities so the
example he would give something just to
make this concrete
uh the example he gives is like if a
kangaroo didn't have a tail could still
hop
around his australian influence showing
there
uh and what lewis meant by that was um
that that sentence is vague and the
reason it's vague is
it's not clear what we mean by that if a
kangaroo didn't have a token still hop
around does that mean that the kangaroo
is an adult or a child does it mean that
are the laws of gravity still the same
are we still in australia uh is this a
martian colony
where we've somehow replicated the
climatological conditions of australia
but the gravity is different
such that the kangaroo might still be
able to get away with hopping or not and
the point is that the sentence
if the kangaroo didn't have a tail
credit still hop isn't doing that work
for us
it's not specifying the environment in
in a more ai
way of saying that uh there's a
misspecification or an under
specification at work in that
sentence and so what lewis says is
basically the game of counterfactuals
is to be confident in your willingness
to trade off
vagueness we still say sentences like
that and we still more or less know what
they mean based
of the context of the utterance so to
corroborate what was said in one of the
talks about how
the way you should specify a system
depends on the context in which it was
specified and the robot should
understand that
i think lewis actually has a pretty rich
language for helping us make sense of
situations like this
so this notion of what it means for a
situation to be somewhat vaguely
specified
is the key takeaway here so he his work
is full of
diagrams like this i apologize this is
very pixelated uh basically what
what lewis would do is illustrate some
sequence or
degree of possible worlds farther and
farther removed from actuality which is
the world
in fact as we as it is right now as we
experience it right now
for the sake of attempting to roughly
formalize
degrees of comparison so like how far
removed is a world where
uh a kangaroo without a tail could still
technically be able to hop if it was on
mars
versus a world where a kangaroo with
half a tail could probably still get
away with hopping if it was an on earth
or something like this
and so what what lewis was trying to do
was say
the language isn't completely doing the
work for us but it can come with a
counter factual logic
that will enable us to remain confident
in
what we think the semantic scope of
those utterances is
and so i won't go into all the the
details of his language here i just want
to emphasize the contrast between this
approach
and and what pearl was proposing is
proposing
which is you know we we need to have a
language
in in ai for degrees of comparative
similarity
uh that are not simply amenable to
optimization
or straightforward parameterization
because that entails
uh an intuitive notion of how distant we
are from actuality
so how distant is a world in which avs
are common enough
that that simulation would hold versus
one
in which avs are like barely on the
horizon
in the minds of pedestrians or other
drivers but where the simulation might
still work under
under very well specified conditions
this is the kind of intuition that lewis
i think was trying to get at in in much
of his philosophical
work and so when he talks about the
vagueness of
overall similarity what he means is that
specification is not simply a formal
problem
it is also determined partially by
consensus and convention
his dissertation work in fact was on
convention in fact the example he used
in that
in his dissertation was uh the main one
was why it is people drive on one side
of the road of one countries
and on the other side of the road and
others uh so even as examples i think
speak
what very directly to to a lot of the
the kind of specific questions they aim
at automated vehicle type problems
but this this difference between
specification being
basically a normative problem of
consensus making
versus specification being a technical
problem of featurization or optimization
is i think very deep and very rich and
something that we should be thinking
about more systematically
rather than treating it as downstream
from modeling assumptions
um and i think i i don't want to sound
like a mystic here and i don't want to
sound defeatist when i say this stuff i
think it is possible to do
formal work that corroborates many of
these intuitions that is good
and that also can make sense to
stakeholders and
the analogy that i would just make here
is i think what lewis is trying to get
at
with this this line of reasoning is
analogous to
the the distinction between real
analysis and calculus
which i think calculus is kind of more
more similar to
to the graphical model approach where
it's a very
interesting valuable tool for specific
domains
that are already well specified and
already amenable to algebraically
determined dynamics
so you can use calculus very richly to
understand newtonian mechanics in a
physical sense
but that's partly a problem of the way
in which
there's a very well defined set of
empirics
behind observing you know in in that
original context
the movement of the cosmos was something
we could constantly observe every night
uh there was a way in which the tool of
calculus was very well suited to that
physical domain
and it's not automatically suited to
other physical domains and so real
analysis is kind of the dirty grinding
work behind calculus saying
here is why this works given certain
assumptions that are reasonable in this
way and not in other ways
and this is really the way in which we
should think about causality
and the way in which we should think of
lewis's contribution and this
willingness to engage in a conversation
about the degrees of comparison between
possible worlds
uh rather than just assuming that the
world is already a discrete action space
that we can just learn enough about to
optimize over it
which i don't think is how the world
works and it's certainly not how other
possible worlds work once avs become
common
to give another example of this treating
something like chickenpox
using reinforcement learning is not
going to be the same thing as treating
sepsis
uh and the reason is that chickenpox and
sepsis are not
the same kind of pathology they are not
just distinct diseases
the nature of the pathology is different
different numbers of people are affected
the diseases are not chronic in the same
way
they are not terminal in the same way
the normative stakes of the diseases
cannot be compared with each other
a lot of this informal work is done
through bedside manner this is what
doctors do okay when they're consulting
with the patient
they're making real-time decisions that
are largely intuitive
based off of decades or years of
experience about what
state of what illness this kind of a
person is experiencing
based off of what i can tell they're
feeling and i'm not just
in principle we can formalize this stuff
in principle yes it is a specification
problem
but some of the work of that
specification is done by institutions
some of that work is done by the way we
educate doctors it's not done in terms
of the actual decision pipeline of like
how we go about diagnosing an illness
and how we map inputs onto outputs
a lot of these mechanisms are informal
and the work of making them formal is
normative and not strictly technical
so sorry just just declare if this was
included chickenpox is on the left
sepsis is on the right
that's i'm not a domain expert but
that's just what those slides were
so just to sum up what i think the
takeaway here
uh what that that we can to put
graphical models in a kind of richer
context
is that there's there's no free lunch
okay there's a price to using them
you have to be willing to pay some
degree or some
measure of metaphysical inaccuracy in
return for a determinate formulation of
objects under conditions of uncertainty
which means that the value of graphical
models and model based rl
i should say by extension is that its
value is proportionate to its
applicability to the situation
and you can't pretend that it's just a
problem with node uncertainties
it has to also be a problem of defining
worthwhile inaccuracies
and i think in order to make sense of
that you are going to have to speak in
the medical context you are going to
have to speak to doctors
you are going to have to speak to
clinicians you are going to have to
speak to nurses
because the consensus-driven nature of
treating
certain kinds of illnesses demands a
different kind of specification problem
that includes formal modeling but is not
restricted to it
so i want to move on to that that leads
i think quite naturally into the second
topic i want to discuss which is this
notion of normative
indeterminacy uh so the contrast here
is that i think a lot of work at present
in this landscape of machine ethics or
value alignment
is is often a term used in the eye
safety landscape
and also sometimes discussed in
reinforcement learning conversations
that i've had
is that machine ethics should be
understood as a problem with normative
uncertainty
which is we're designing systems that
can be learning from us
about what is the good what is good
behavior what actions are better than
others
what actions should be prohibited when
and how and
so just to say that somewhat more
abstractly the question
of normative uncertainty is what should
be the criteria for discovering
evaluating and resolving harms among
stakeholders
and a dominant position or i should just
say representative position this
landscape has been put forward by
william mccaskill
uh in his dissertation originally he's
expanded on it since then called
metanormativism
uh and the idea behind metanormativism
is yes okay they're all these norms
that govern why people act as they do in
certain ways
um and basically systems need to learn
those things
so if crudely we're faced with something
like a trolley problem
where i don't know or i'm not confident
in whether i should
switch the route of the car to take a
certain kind of
action over another what the question
behind metanormativism is well look
it's an empirical problem in part what
additional information would you need
to aggregate in order to resolve the
uncertainty what better version of route
planning
what better rl policy okay would you
need
such that the optimization could do a
lot of the work for you uh
and i just want to emphasize here that
this position rests
often like on a kind of implicit analogy
between
the the uncertainty of like all the
different norms that are at stake
in in a driving context let's say and
empirical observability
the idea is that if you leverage the
ability of the system to learn
it could basically do a better job or
more consistent job of following norms
even that humans do
so we could optimize over not just what
an actual human driver might do but also
what a transportation planner might do
and what a governor might do
simultaneously because of its ability to
observe these different dynamics at the
same time
note that the dynamics are still
deterministic in this frame
now i i just again want to hit this
intuition that
the part of the problem with that is
that
social systems as a whole can be
understood as dynamical systems in which
intervening on one layer even just by
observing it
affects the other layers there in you
know pick any of these contexts we've
discussed already in this boot camp
whether it's medicine whether it's
transportation whether it's
climate change i mean almost anything
there is some
implicit hierarchy of expertise and
domain trust such that if you intervene
on one part of the pyramid
you are going to reshape the other parts
economic sociologists call this
performativity
other disciplines might have other names
for it the point is that
when you are observing the world you are
by definition
also in a certain relationship with that
world and
what your entry point is to
observability whether it's an api
whether it's some legacy database from
which you can learn is not neutral
because it was also created by some of
these stakeholders
so there's a sense of responsibility
to that context that i think transcends
the frame of meta-normativism and so
that's when i'm saying
i'm expanding that definition here
through reference to vagueness and
saying the issue is really more this
normative indeterminacy
not normative uncertainty you can't
simply discover
or encode norms of behavior you are also
making them
by choosing the practical conditions
under which you are developing an ai
system
and what that means is that developing
safe ai or value-aligned ai through like
the crafting of rules or like what sorts
of validation you trust
is also about developing practices
in in in yourself and in your
relationship with
whoever was previously trusted with
managing that domain
and translating value commitments into
the formalism
and again often this work this work
always happens it has to and the
system's not going to work
it just usually happens behind the
scenes and i think there needs to be
more honesty about that indeterminacy
such that like you're saying like look i
could do this more than one way
we don't have to treat this illness any
particular way i'm choosing to do it
this way because that seems legitimate
and that has to be justified it's not
pre-given it's not something
discoverable
by more accurately observing the domain
or the data available to you
so i'm going to circle back to a point i
made near the start of this talk
about these different canonical schools
of thought
for resolving issues of vagueness
and i should say this part in particular
is based off of a working paper
uh with with two of my collaborators
here that there are basically three
canonical ways of resolving
patterns of indeterminacy one is to say
there is a precise boundary out there
and maybe we could discover it but we
don't precisely know where it is yet
um and this is based i see
metanormativism as a as a contemporary
equivalent to this ancient position of
epistemicism
the idea that in this case in fact there
is some
precise grains of sand that constitute a
heap
but it's not at present available to us
to know what that is and it's it's it's
an empirical question
we could we could do some experiments so
we could we could hire some
psychologists
and get them to do a better job of
understanding the cognitive mechanisms
behind human reasoning
to see where that boundary is another
approach is semantic indeterminism which
is
this is often associated with
wittenstein the idea is there are
multiple language communities and that
they might use the word heap differently
and so we just have to accept that there
is a kind of constrained
confined pluralism in in what the
answers to that question are based off
of the number of language communities
that in fact exist
and then finally you could argue no
actually there's no boundary for harm
there's no boundary for what it means to
make an intervention good or bad because
society is vague
it might be an object you don't think is
even possible to define well
and so therefore you could argue we
might as well
replace a lot of uh human driven medical
interventions with rl policies
because there's really no one to say
that the system won't be just as good
uh and it's it's we have a reason to
think on the opposite the system might
be
better because at least we can know
deterministically how it works and you
can't know that about people
so again i want to circle back and say i
think all of these positions are
accurate i think they're all real
i think they're all true i think the
opposition is a misnomer
because what you are doing when you're
developing an ai system is making
commitments along each of these axes
what you were doing at design time at
training time
and deployment time is making
commitments
within the domain of each of these
positions there is some degree to which
there is there are boundaries of what
norms count or what actions are okay
but there's uncertainty about that and
it's possible that you can design the
system in a way that it could learn more
accurately what those things are
it's also true that people think of the
world differently and have somewhat
different semantics to make sense of it
that has to be respected and it's also
the case
that some people are different from each
other in such a way that has
no semantic equivalent that there is no
basis for comparison for it
and that has to be also included in how
you design these systems
particularly the integration time it
which is to say at deployment time
to make this concrete again potholes
most avs at present
understandably are developed and trained
in such a way to avoid potholes
makes sense why we want them to go in
potholes it would make the roads worse
it might harm the vehicle it might scare
the passengers and the cars
other drivers would be confused why
they're doing this let's not go in them
the thing is potholes are not natural
features of the environment
these are not things that are out there
in the world before cars exist
they're only ever created by things
like the systems we were designing so
what you were doing
when you were building an av is you are
deciding
whether we should care about the fact
that potholes exist
the more common avs become the more
pressing that normative question becomes
if we decide that the most important
thing for avs to do
is avoid potholes potholes will become
more common
public investment in roads will be
compromised
the nature of what it means to drive and
be a passenger will be different
i know that sounds weird i'm not saying
we should deliberately program the
vehicles to be willing to go into
potholes
what i'm saying is the thresholds for
how
the cars engage in route planning needs
to be justified
partially by the normative context
of what roads are for there needs to be
a tighter coordination between route
planning
as an optimization problem and public
policy planning
another example is jaywalking if we make
cars robust
to not hit people but only worry about
certain ways of hitting people because
we consider them to be most likely
we are effectively deciding how we want
society to wrap around babies
in a way that we didn't have to what it
means to
jaywalk people is to make
certain kinds of human behavior
stigmatized or disincentivized
because the dominant mode of
transportation would be compromised
unless that thing is put into a second
tier or third tier position
this is a kind of danger that i think av
people often just don't think about
because the goal is to make the car safe
no matter what
they should be safe no matter what the
point is safety is
indeterminate we you know 30 000 people
die every year right now from cars
that that's that's just been a reality
we've been willing to accept
maybe we shouldn't accept that world
maybe we should aim for something better
but the point is part of the reason
we're willing to live with that is that
we don't like
how much control there would have to be
in order for that
rate of death to be reduced and
the point is that if you don't want
people to be made into jaywalkers
you have to give them a seat at the
table you have to be willing to say
where should pedestrians be permitted to
walk in a way that they would accept as
legitimate
rather than just making the cars drive
so conservatively
that we basically make the burden of
responsibility
fall on people to understand the cars as
driving differently than human drivers
rather than the other way around
i'll circle back to this a bit more
later in the talk and then finally i
want to briefly give this example of uh
what's what's been called moral crumple
zones
uh coming out of work uh by uh madeleine
ellis i believe is her name
uh which which basically is this
interesting point that
it's it's often been the case that when
avs crash
or when they harm people or even when
they hit a pedestrian
uh the humans are blamed whether it's
the pedestrian
whether it's the person who is nominally
behind the wheel
uh who own the vehicle or whether it's
like the local regulatory infrastructure
because they as was said did not
sufficiently understand what to expect
from the system
and this question of like where the
burden of responsibility lies
is not something that i that i really
see addressed in much formal work right
now
but it needs to be because otherwise
again we're going to live in a world
where the systems are trivially safe
but we implicitly begin to think of
people as
less safe in and of themselves
because we're cognitively limited we're
more engaged in habit
than we are in like active awareness of
what we can expect from these cars at
all times
and so this this work of defining what
we should reasonably expect
people to engage in when they are
engaging with these vehicles
should be part of the way we specify
these models
because if we don't and we just let
model specification do all the work
we effectively let those systems decide
the way
transportation should operate and make
anybody who doesn't get that
bear bear the cost either legally or
or financially in in some other some
other informal way
so what this what this climax is in this
again is drawing from this paper i've
written with my collaborators
is this hard choices and artificial
intelligence framework where
these different sources of indeterminacy
in a given ai pipeline are
all relevant and have to be respected
and those choices need to be made
explicit
about the fact that we could have
specified the system differently
it's indeterminate how we should have
done so here is our reasoning for why
we're doing it
and allowing a kind of descent to be
integrated into the pipeline
such that other stakeholders at least
have the ability to contest those
assumptions
and if that work isn't done again you
will end up with a system that's optimal
according to its own
specification trivially but it will be
misaligned
in in any meaningful way from the world
that we want it to be optimal against
so i i'm happy to engage in with people
in conversation about
you know how this framework works what i
mean by these different these different
terms here
i just want to communicate the high
level intuition in in this talk
and then finally i want to end with this
concept of situated publics which is um
a follow-up paper that i'm now writing
with one of my collaborators on this
original paper
um which i think provides a kind of uh a
lens for thinking about
this this work as making these hard
choices as as partly political
and and not and not simply a matter of
analytic reasoning or of personal ethics
that this that you are engaging in in
genuinely difficult choices with other
stakeholders who might disagree with you
and that needs to be acknowledged so
this is now where i'm going to introduce
um you know my lab at berkeley the
center of human compatible ai
as i said before this is a lab led by
stuart russell the goal of chai
as we call it affectionately uh is to
build provably beneficial systems
uh which is to say you know systems that
are value aligned systems that we know
or have reason to think will follow
human intentions
and chai you know engages deeply with
this
this work on normative normative
uncertainty uh that i mentioned before
most of my technical standpoint rather
than a philosophical one
and what i've been doing uh for about
four years now
is you know uh hanging out there and
helping them think about this uh you
know not simply technical but also more
socio-technical
and and political landscape of of what
it means to design a safe system
uh this slide is just to kind of give a
taste of the kind of
field work that i've been doing uh which
includes you know several years of
participant observation
interviews uh many many you know
productive collaborations and
conversations with members of that lab
and also adjacent research institutes
and i i just want to provide that as a
frame to sort of say
like to to kind of stick the landing in
terms of like how i think these issues
with normal
uncertainty are relevant to ai safety
as a whole and not and not merely to how
we should think about civilian abs
um and so chai kind of in the past and
its work has kind of had this
distinctive approach to
how we should resolve these these
problems that i've been discussing which
is that we should assign roles
uh distinctive rules to humans and
machines
uh to make it possible for systems to to
do what we actually want them to do
so this could be human robot interaction
uh
as a field it could be something even
more specific like inverse reinforcement
learning
uh or cooperative irl is is the
particular paper i'm thinking of right
now
uh this is what that means is basically
that the human
has a pedagogic stance the human is
teaching the robot
how to do an activity the robot observes
the agent observes
and it observes enough times with enough
assumptions that it is then able
eventually to autonomously perform the
activity at a high level
um that doesn't resolve this issue of
trust as chinos
humans can't always be trusted to be
good be good pedagogues be good teachers
we're often recent work has found we're
better uh when we're ignorant
and we don't even know we're trying to
teach the robot we're just engaging the
activity naturally
uh which raises like what we should do
when humans who are nominally good at
the activity can't actually be trusted
to play the role well
so to give you know some examples of
this
um again the way chai approaches this is
that there
are certain like delineable challenges
in in a robot's life such as like
figuring out what to optimize
optimizing it in an environment with
others and delineating all the different
sorts of roles that are at stake not
just the user but also
also the robot designer and one example
of like the way this is often like
framed and i mean anka talked about this
as well is
if you imagine the the red car here is
an automated vehicle
and it's trying to merge into the left
lane which at present as a human driver
uh the robot might do something like the
following uh which is
if it's trying to figure if it melts
assume it doesn't know
you know what the human is likely to do
if it takes
if the if the car motions to merge into
that lane
so what it might do is it could start to
merge
in a deliberately aggressive fashion uh
in a way that you know it would signal
you know briefly and then just
immediately start to go into the lane
and particularly like with the intent
of observing what how the human will
respond to that action
if the human uh slows down uh
the the av might take that as an
indication that okay it's safe for me to
continue and it'll complete the merger
uh and what it'll implicitly be doing is
like updating its model of the human
as a as basically a passive driver as
someone who's like
not going to challenge the av or might
not or yeah otherwise just
is not something to be concerned about
and not going to impede the merger
if the human however does not notice or
aggressively speeds up or something
similar
the av might take that indication of
like okay whoa i need to back off here
i need to stay in my original lane um
and this this is a way of conceiving of
like okay so was that safe
um and and i give this as an example
again of like okay yes that
that's safe as illustrated but
effectively what you were doing if all
we do
is is constrain the problem to these
parameters
is choosing the kinds of drivers that
uh the car is going to work with and the
kinds that it won't
so if you trace this out to a world in
which avs comprise most vehicles
uh or some like large minority of
vehicles
um we are going to have to change the
way humans take driver's exams
because there is no way we are going to
let most humans continue to drive cars
if avs are doing this on a regular basis
uh there is no way we're going to let
most pedestrians continue to act
as natural pedestrians in a world where
avs are constantly nudging
to find marginal boundaries based off of
what kind of model of that person they
think would be safe under certain
regimes of expectation
um the model works as specified
but you are changing the semantics of
driving the semantics of the road or at
stake
when you're engaging in work like this
so if you look at the way
like actual av pipelines are structured
to illustrate some of these
indeterminate issues i was describing
abstractly before
trade-offs between perception and
rooting like happen
and they are significant and they're
often again like informal
because these teams are distinct at the
way these companies in the way of many
of these companies are set up
a lot of the work that goes into
localization into routing into
prediction into planning
rest on distinct kinds of choices that
need to be better coordinated
with respect to what different kinds of
stakeholders would see is legitimate
you can trivially find some optimization
across all these different arrows
that is internally going to be
consistent and is going to not kill
people
but that's not all that we mean when we
talk about avs being safe
in fact i don't think it's very much of
what we mean when we speak of av as
being safe
most people surveys at presents say most
people still are not going to want to
ride in these things
and the reason is that at present
there's still really no equivalent
anywhere near the level of like
sophistication
behind this like decades-long process of
certification
that has been enforced by the department
transportation
uh fhwa uh nitsa organizations that have
extremely well specified metrics
corroborated human factors corroborating
driving scenarios corroborated and crash
testing
to show exactly what the boundaries
between different kinds of safety are
i can say a lot more about this if i'm
running out of time but the point is
like we
we need to get better at defining these
normative regimes these normative
boundaries
against which different kinds of safety
first of all makes sense
and secondly are understood to be either
a matter of like the physical parameters
of the car
or the cognitive parameters of the
driver or
the physical parameters of the road and
the thing is right now we sort of expect
avs to like inherit all of those things
in in a way that we can just sort of
optimize over rather than understanding
maybe that delineation is out of date
and that's interesting
but there needs to be a delineation
there need to be specified roles
that corroborate not just the
relationship between the robot designer
and the user
but also the robot designer the city
planner
the the the person who updates signage
on stop signs and paves over asphalt
different sorts of pedestrians
all of these people need to have a seat
at the table exactly what that looks
like i don't know
but that's the kind of normative
coordination we're going to need
uh in order to resolve this and i think
this quote
from andrew ing is illustrative of the
danger here uh in my interviews with
with many regulators i bring this up he
as he said this um
as an example say rather than building
ai to solve the pogo stick problem
we should partner with the government to
ask people to be lawful and considerate
safety isn't just about the quality
of the ai technology um and again this
is what i mean when i say safety is
indeterminate
it's a matter of responsibility and it's
a matter of commitment the question is
not how do we get cars to not do damage
the question is what counts as damage
that there is no boundary for that at
present or the boundaries are very
roughly fixed
and we need to decide if those are the
vouchers we want and if they are
whose responsibility is it to maintain
them is it the public's responsibility
to make av safe by expecting less of
them that's the kind of vision
that i think is at stake in this quote
is whether
avs are inevitable and whether in
response to that
we should basically accept that roads
are just going to change in ways that we
can't control
maybe that's the future maybe it's not i
mean this is the sort of conversation
that i think we should be having
at a technical level as well as on a
political level
so what i'm doing right now uh with my
collaborator i just want to illustrate
this very briefly
is in here is uh incorporating this
notion of situated publics
into how we should do the
parameterization
behind rooting so what this model this
is sort of influenced by work by john
dewey
a long time ago and james gronig more
recently who's a
kind of public relations expert is that
you you think about parameterization
not just as model optimization but as
the the relationship between
the most affected stakeholders and the
designer
it would which could be the av designer
in this case and that there is a zone
of comparability of expectation in which
both groups have their interests being
met
their commitments are both being
corroborated and that zone might be
roughly fixed but it can still be fixed
so the trade-off between perception and
routing for example in an av
we want that to fall in the win-win zone
we don't want it to arbitrarily follow
in
one on this diagram of pure asymmetry
where the av company says look the cars
are safe as specified
you just should have not been in that
intersection at that time or not been on
your smartphone or
you know not not jaywalking in this way
and
and that's what's really your fault
that's that's the that's the main
parameterization bottleneck
in my mind it's not so much weather and
simulation you can get these things to
be safe
it's can you get a critical threshold of
stakeholders
to understand what the system is going
to do
and to accept it as and not just accept
it but affirm
their own interests um so i'm writing
this right now this is sort of more
setting an agenda that is presenting a
final solution
um but but those are now the three i've
covered now the three things i want to
say
so to put it all together i kind of this
final slide
of what the takeaways are here i think
that there needs to be more work done
on identifying the relevant domain
indeterminacies
and defining their relationship
according to roughly fixed parameters
uh and that that work is going to
partially be technical is also going to
entail
a reform in how the institutions
themselves are going to operate where
doctors work
how we update the signage on roads how
we go about
deciding what the world is going to be
in which these agents can be
optimal and i think that's going to be a
very large undertaking about controlling
defining and democratizing
uh the features of defining the features
of safety critical systems as a natural
extension of technical work
so um i i have a lot more thoughts on
this and there are a lot more case
studies we
consider uh but but i'll stop there and
and hopefully we still have some time
for questions so so thank you for this
opportunity
thanks very much tom uh that was
fascinating we do have
a few minutes for questions uh there's
actually
uh one question in the q a so feel free
to add them there if you want if you
are in um in this panelist category feel
free to turn on your
uh video unmute yourself and and ask a
question
uh so um in the
in the q a arena asks apologies if you
already mentioned this and i missed it
but did you address the impact of
adversarial efforts and data poisoning
on optimization
yeah i think that so okay so as far as
um i guess i touched on this
briefly not in those terms with respect
to like adversarial learning i think is
a very second
like domain and i think that i mean the
the example i always go to in my head i
mean when i think about it is
yeah i mean you know you stick a piece
of gum on a stop sign
and the neuron that classifies it as a
giraffe you know rather than a stop sign
okay that's bad
um we should we should use adversarial
learning so that's not true
it's not a panacea and the reason is
indeterminacy
you cannot adversarially learn all your
way to understanding what a stop sign is
i wish you could the reason is that stop
signs are not natural features of the
environment
for the for the first years cars existed
there were no stop signs
okay were the cars safe i mean
astonishingly somewhat yeah they were
and the reason is that everyone knew
there weren't stop signs
so when people entered into situations
where they had to be careful
they were careful there was no discreet
decision heuristic by which people like
always programmatically stopped
looked around at a four-way stop and
then moved ahead that scheme
is already a specification of the
environment and it entailed
a larger discussion about updating
windshields
to make them large enough that you could
see things like stop signs
what color stop signs should be like
this is not new
a lot of these problems are not new it's
just that the the
learning environment is new because we
have new tools at our disposal
so what that implies is there's a
certain threshold that i don't think
we've discovered yet
where we can get these cars good enough
so they don't misclassify stop signs
with guns stuck on them
but they still can't see every stop sign
and we need to decide at that point
whether that means that stop signs
themselves
should be rebuilt in such a way that the
neural nets can perform adequately
or whether there are certain kinds of
roads where they shouldn't be allowed on
because for whatever reason the stop
signs are grimier or there's something
wrong with their ability to reliably
recognize the signage
there are people whose job it is to do
signage
we should be talking to those people we
should either be paying them more
or hire more of them uh and it really
just rests on this question of whether
you think
that the cars are built for the road or
the roads are built for the cars
my concern is that we're going to end up
in a place where so many resources are
poured into adversarial learning
that we just sort of make the roads
conform to the model specification
the entire point of a model is to be con
is to conform to the world
that's the work that we should be doing
it's hard work it is
partly technical but it's predominantly
socio-technical
they've probably said enough yeah um
that's great so uh there's a question
from manuel
uh in in the chat now uh about the
reception you see so
so much of ai ethics among computer
scientists seems to stay on discussions
of technical fixes
or in abstract situations like the
trolley problem instead of these deep
socio-technical
questions that engage with normative
philosophical questions about
epistemology and metaphysics and such
how does this work seem received and or
internalized in cs and ai circles
as opposed to say sts
yeah okay that's a great question um
that's a great question
i mean a lot of this talk was my own
result from asking myself that question
so so i i i'm not comfortable portraying
myself as an authority on these
communities
although i've published in both and and
collaborated with members in both
my impression is that there is a lot of
mistrust from the sts community
about uh the
the dominant perspectives in machine
ethics and value alignment
now there are a lot of reasons for that
mistrust
uh but i think it can be summed up in
yeah this this difference between
whether you think the world
is a discrete action space or not in a
sense the entire point of sts is to say
that it's not
the world is fluid it is dynamic it is
continuous
you can discretize the world okay you
can
define action spaces uh within it you
can make an environment in which a
system like this can learn
but the work of doing that remakes the
world
it is no longer the same domain it is no
longer going to follow the same norms
it is no longer going to have the same
semantics um
and i think at present the sts community
is so
anxious about that basic fact
that they are inclined to to to distrust
a lot of the work that's being done in
machine ethics my approach
is pragmatic which is to say this is an
opportunity to refashion
the norms by which we want certain
domains to work
i don't think cars are aligned with
humans right now
i don't think they've been aligned ever
and
i think you know it distresses me that
we accept it as a price
as the price of political economy that
tens of thousands of people die every
year
just because of the convenience of what
these cars provide i don't think that's
an aligned system
i recognize that's my ethics talking
but what i want is more honesty
and i i should really say more more
humility from both sides
in the sense that uh
technics remake the world and there is a
kind of agency there uh
normatively speaking that i think the
sts community should should learn
from and that the machine ethics
community
should maybe be more humble in relation
to and and not just think that that
creating a research design of simulation
is going to make your system um you know
optimal enough that it should be
deployed at scale i'll stop there
i i'm saying too much again so we're
actually out of time you have a bunch
more questions there
they do get saved you'll have a chance
to see them all but unfortunately not
address them here um fascinating area
hugely important
and and that was a really really uh
amazing talk thanks very much
tom uh we appreciate it thank you and
just to advertise
we we have another we have a science
communicator in residence talk at the
same time next week so
um hope to see you all for that thanks
again tom